in this exercise we will explore how to
download the genome again clinical data
set from the International Cancer Genome
consortium database covers the data into
a matrix table and convert the ensembl
annotation or ENS GID to the human
genome organization or Hugo gene
nomenclature HGSE to download the data
set we will first go to Google
search for the ICGC webpage
once you are in you can go directly to
the data portal
go to data repositories
select the donor tab on top
select the type of cancer that you're
interested at the primary site tab
next select the project
now you will see that there are a lot of
data under the PACA au project with 2507
files in total of 26 point one five
terabytes this include the aligned reads
BAM files you can download these files
if you are interested to reanalyze the
data in most cases we will just download
the summary files for each donor
to do that we will select the donors dab
on top here select download donor data
you will get a pop-up asking you what
type of data you want to download in
this case we will select all
the data will then be downloaded to your
computer
once it is finished downloading you can
extract the files in the designated
folder
you
you will notice that the file size is
extremely huge for example the
methylation data set is 19 gigabytes you
will not be able to open it with the
default notepad or Excel
you will need other software which can
handle big data sets such as R or etc in
this exercise we will use a proprietary
software called delimit which can handle
big data set once you open the file into
limit you will soon notice that there
are a lot of information that is
redundant for example you will see that
each row of the data represent a gene
expression of a particular sample the
file consists of more than 4 million
rows representing a 42,000 gene
expression from 96 samples for your
information the maximum number of row
Microsoft Excel can handle is 1 million
next we are going to convert the data
set into a matrix table which will allow
us to run most of the analysis later on
first we will remove some of the columns
that are not important for us
you
we will retain the submitted sample ID
gene ID and normalized read count
columns
you
under the split on column field select
the column on which you wish to split up
the file next under the save result
files in field specify the folder where
each result file will be saved
specify the name that is to be used for
each result file use the reserve string
percent val as a placeholder for the
column value that will be added to the
file name once it is ready click on the
split button to start splitting up the
file the operation will run in the
background allowing you to continue to
work the progress indicator on the
status bar will show the progress of the
operation if you need to abort the
operation press the Escape key once it
is done splitting you can check on the
files
note that in the designated folder the
file names are based on the submitted
sample ID column in our original data
set to form the matrix we will now join
the split files together horizontally
you
once the joining is complete you can
open the file in Excel for further
pre-processing
you
first we will transform the data set
using the text to columns function
select tab is the delimiter
you
next we will annotate the submitted
sample ID on each column
you
then we will sort horizontally
to ensure that the gene ID from each
sample is matched we will use the county
function in Excel if all the gene IDs
are matched it should return a total
number of sample size minus one which is
you
now that we have ascertained that the
gene IDs are matched we can remove the
unnecessary column and form a data
matrix
you
finally we will convert the ensembl gene
ID into the HG NC gene symbol to do that
we will use the ensembl biomart
you
go to the filters tab in biomart
select genes stable ID on to the input
external ID list tab
copy the ensembl gene ID from our data
set into a notepad document and attach
this file
you
then got to the attributes tab select
gene stable ID NH GNC symbol
you
once it is ready press count
you can obtain the results by pressing
alt stab export the results to TSV file
finally you can use the vlookup function
in Excel to match the ensembl gene ID
into the H GNC gene symbol
you